the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC an anti-abortion
anti-lgbt Christian group pulled the
stunt to get themselves refused service
at a restaurant and now you've got a lot
of right Wingers saying they were denied
service for their religion is that
actually what happened I want to start
with this today because it is so
important to understand when we talk
about non-discrimination
differences between beliefs and identity
and this is the perfect example to talk
about that so let's start with an
article that tells us what happened it's
a CVS CBS News article restaurant denies
Christian group service over its
anti-abortion and lgbtq stances here's
what happened
a restaurant in Richmond Virginia
refused to host a private event for a
Conservative Christian organization over
the group's position on same-sex
marriage and abortion rights the
restaurant is called Metzger bar and
Butchery and it is known as an inclusive
establishment that has rarely refused
service to willing patrons but said it
denied service to the group in an effort
to protect its staff many of whom are
members remember women or members of the
lgbtq community quote we recent recently
we reviewed service to a group that had
booked an event with us after the owners
of Metzger found out it was a group of
donors to a political organization that
seeks to deprive women in lgbtq persons
of their basic human rights in Virginia
the move was consistent with Metzger's
past practices was made out of respect
for its staff quote we have always
refused service to anyone for making our
staff uncomfortable or unsafe and this
was the driving force behind our
decision all of our staff were people
with rights who deserve dignity and a
safe work environment this is a super
interesting legal story because
discrimination along religious lines
meaning we don't serve Christians would
be against the law but political beliefs
are not protected outside of Washington
D.C and that is what is at the Crux of
this now I'm biased my view here is that
nowhere is there any evidence that these
folks were denied service for being
Christian
they were denied service for their views
on particular issues their view on
abortion their view on LGBT rights
now where it starts to get dicey is that
as we have seen the religious right uh
uh start to behave over the last few
years is to argue well those views are
informed by our religion and by telling
us that those views are what is getting
us banned or refused service you were
effectively discriminating against our
religion because there is no daylight
between our view on abortion and LGBT
rights and our Christian faith
now the other part that's important to
consider is that this was a stunt the
Family Foundation is the name of the
group that did this they obviously knew
about Metzger's history of supporting
inclusivity including LGBT inclusivity
they knew that they tried to book an
event there and after they said no they
started soliciting donations because oh
we've been canceled they've canceled us
where this was a very clear and known
stunt and this was the outcome so
there's a couple different things that I
think are important to talk about uh
from a legal standpoint I can't
adjudicate here whether based on all of
the facts a court would find saying no
was because of Christianity or saying no
was because of political views that are
not protected by non-discrimination law
the truth is we all know there are
progressive Christian groups Progressive
Catholic groups Etc
endless uh uh Jewish groups that have
very different views about abortion
there's no rule that says if you are
quote Christian
you have to have this particular view
about abortion or about LGBT people so
we know that you have other perspectives
there and so
it's obvious that If This Were a
progressive Christian group or a
Christian group that had a let others
decide view we don't like it but let
others decide about abortion or whatever
the case may be they would not have been
refused service and so by definition
that is not religiously based
discrimination the problem is that
thanks to what happened to the Judiciary
in the United States under Donald Trump
one of the biggest victories that
genuinely took place during the Trump
Administration was
the ability of Donald Trump and the
success for Donald Trump of moving the
Judiciary dramatically to the right in
the United States now most prominently
we think about the Supreme Court and of
course that is prominent that's what
most of us know about long public
confirmation hearings we know the names
of these folks Etc
but at many other levels the appointment
of right-wing judges by Donald Trump has
led to a Judiciary that is much more
likely to find
even though really they say it's the
views not the religion you can't
separate those religious views and this
is effectively religiously based
discrimination you must host the Family
Foundation there are judges in the
United States that would find that and
that's very very scary now at the back
or the bottom or the top of this however
you want to describe it
there's always the hypocrisy with these
people they want to have it both ways on
the one hand they want to be able to
discriminate against the LGBT people
whether it's the anti-gay Baker or
whatever story you want to look at they
want that freedom
but they also want everyone else to have
to accept and suck up and allow their
bigotry and their discrimination and
their whatever it may be in the
particular circumstance xenophobia or
homophobia or whatever the case may be
and then they frame it as religious when
they want to do the Discrimination it's
their right because of their religion
and then when they want to demand that
they be serviced they say it's
discrimination not to serve us they want
it both ways there is not
a lot of exciting stuff happening in
Hospitality from the from the pers from
this particular perspective right now
but the right to refuse service is a
real thing and as long as you're not
violating non-discrimination law which
includes religion
Etc uh then you should be allowed to do
it I believe that the restaurant was
well within its rights to say because of
your views they didn't even mention
their religion because if your views we
are not going to offer you service we
will see what it leads to in terms of
lawsuits and if there is an outcome then
we will get to that there is something
fascinating and delightful happening
since Herschel Walker lost his election
in Georgia on Tuesday which is the
Republican blame game it's your fault
it's your fault hey who said not to vote
early anyway that wasn't a good idea why
didn't more Senators go to uh Georgia to
campaign for Herschel Walker they're all
pointing fingers and the most important
takeaway here to me
is this was something they brought on
themselves we're going to listen to all
sorts of different finger pointing here
we're starting with um Ari Fleischer
former Bush Administration official on
the Sean Hannity program last night
saying you need good candidates starting
to point to the candidate Choice and
then Hannity says well but the kid
Herschel Walker was a good candidate
this is the best stuff reason that
things are so close down the middle yeah
but the final point I'll make Sean is
mechanics are always important in
campaigns but candidate quality is
essential good candidates will win and
the big issue for Republicans still is
who is our leader who's the candidate at
the top
opportunity to bring people in so
Fleischer seems to both be saying Trump
at the top isn't great for the party and
Walker also wasn't a particularly good
candidate but both of which are arguably
true Herschel I thought was a good
candidate I know people disagree with
that but he got outspent in the runoff
about three to four to one he got
outspent in the general election by an
equal amount that makes a difference
money in politics makes a a pretty big
difference yeah so now all of a sudden
the concern is money in politics for
Sean Hannity because Walker was a good
candidate Walker was not a good
candidate but he almost won anyway
because the electorate in Georgia is so
depraved that they thought this guy is a
better option than Raphael Warnock which
is really wacky stuff then sticking with
Hannity for the time being Hannity says
you know in some cases maybe Republicans
do actually need to pick better
candidates and he says not Walker but he
talks about maybe Doug mastriano
Michigan in some cases Republicans do
need better candidates I'll give you one
example not to pick on Pennsylvania
gubernatorial candidate Doug mastriano
but you look at his position on abortion
he had no exceptions for rape incest the
mother's life you in Pennsylvania I'm
talking politically not morally here you
cannot win morally it's all bad
Pennsylvania yeah with that position it
is simply mathematically impossible a
bad candidate for that race and it had
impact on the entire Republican ticket
so this is just interesting because
you've got Ari Fleischer saying Trump at
the top of the ticket isn't good for
Republicans Walker wasn't a good
candidate then in comes handed me and
says no Walker was a good candidate but
Doug mastriano was not a good candidate
the finger pointing is starting then we
go to kellyanne Conway and kellyanne
Conway's message is the problem is other
Republican Senators it wasn't Herschel
Walker it was that the 49 Republican
Senators didn't go to Georgia to help
Herschel Walker a new new Target of her
blame I think people saying we need a
new message let me just say something
respectfully to the 49 Republican
Senators right where were most of you
right why weren't you in Georgia a few
of them were but they all should have
been gentlemen because they should have
been there at some in some form a
teletown hall in person saying the
following I serve the United State
Senate with Rafael Warnock he's a
terrible Senator he doesn't represent
Georgia he's not fit to serve he votes
to Joe Biden he voted for inflation
reduction act and doesn't do that he
said nothing when they pulled out of
Afghanistan he said nothing that Joe
Biden has been to Delaware 174 days and
down to the Border zero days that's what
needs to happen where were the other
Senators to say I want Herschel Walker
not Raphael Warnock in the Senate with
me this is absolutely the best Okay so
Ari Fleischer says the problem is Trump
at the top of the ticket and Walker's
not a good candidate Hannity says no
Walker was a good candidate Trump at the
top of the ticket's fine but Doug
mastriano was a bad candidate and it was
money in politics that hurt Herschel
Walker kellyanne Conway says the problem
is the incumbent Republican Senators
they should have been there helping
Herschel Walker then we go to Mark Levin
Fox News host he points out hey
Republicans aren't explaining their
positions on any issues that's the
problem the reason people don't vote is
they don't have a reason to vote what
was the Republican position on inflation
what were they going to do I still don't
know well there was no position and he's
not wrong I mean listen Mark Mark Levin
is correctly pointing out
what were they going to do about
inflation now Herschel Walker couldn't
even understand what inflation was he
has no idea what's going on you know up
was down day was night it was for
Herschel Walker it was like a Twilight
Zone there was no way that's why Walker
didn't Express his position but why
haven't Republicans explained what
they're going to do about inflation well
it's because they can't really do
anything about it these things are
cyclical and they're Global and you need
to figure out what can we do until
inflation comes down Beyond we've talked
about what the FED can do Etc that's an
economic discussion but Mark Levin is
now saying they're not expressing their
views on issues correctly
and then the last clip here is Charlie
Kirk and he says Republicans aren't
voting because they don't trust the
process well why don't they trust the
process because Charlie Kirk's Maga
movement that he is a part of has been
saying you can't trust the process you
see
it's interesting I actually assumed
incorrectly that if you take time to
watch this program thank you right
that you would also just automatically
vote turns out there's a fair portion of
you that are completely done and that
are willing to voice that opinion why
would he think that his program which
endlessly talks about how everything's
rigged is going to encourage people to
vote do we have that Laura Ingram clip
that we guys pulled
and I just want to say I do sympathize
with being upset with the Republican
party and not totally trusting the
system but not participating at all
guarantees the other side to be able
to play games and if everything was
broken and lost how did we win the House
of Representatives if everything is
broken and lost how did Ron Johnson who
stood up against the pharmaceutical
company win well he barely won and
Charlie Kirk is Right Charlie Kirk of
course is right and I asked this
question in 2020 they say the
presidential election was rigged but all
the Senators and members of Congress on
the same damn ballots who won they don't
say a peep about those but if it was
rigged that how would there be some
incongruence
and Charlie Kirk is now realizing well
all of this talk about it being rigged
it makes people think it's not worth
voting and that is exactly what we have
been talking about for a long time so
the finger pointing is happening will
they figure it out before 2024 they very
well might they very well might we're
gonna be here with you until then make
sure
you were subscribed to our YouTube
channel
three million people in October we're
trying to figure we'll have the number
for November soon 3.2 million of you in
no in October watched our videos on
YouTube didn't subscribe
Please Subscribe it is free and it does
wonders for us in the YouTube algorithm
we'll take a quick break and be right
back
one of our sponsors today is Leisure of
NYC offering Ultra comfortable fair
trade men's clothing at a fair price
guys know how tough it can be to find
good boxers and t-shirts the Search is
Over All boxer briefs by Leisure of NYC
are made with amazingly soft moisture
wicking viscose from bamboo it feels
super lightweight like air it doesn't
Bunch up it's also great for the planet
Leisure of NYC also makes these
incredible supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts for men less than one percent
of men's Basics today are made with
supima cotton it's the best out there it
feels like Silk quite frankly you can
walk around in a scratchy t-shirt all
day or you can enjoy the cloud soft feel
of supima cotton and actually love the
shirt you're in these are my go-to
shirts and boxers nobody else even comes
close to the Comfort they provide all
products are fair trade with
sustainability in mind pick some up for
yourself or someone on your holiday
shopping list go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below the David packman show is funded
by none other than you we have something
called the membership program you sign
up at joinpakman.com you get every day
you get the full show with no
commercials hours before everybody else
gets it you get the bonus show every
single day Alex Jones hates that damn
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not Dave Pacman well you don't have to
be Dave Pacman to get the bonus show you
can sign up at joinpakman.com you can
use the coupon code 24 starts now and
the next exclusive members only Town
Hall will be announced very very soon
let's get to some Kerry Lake Insanity
Donald Trump recently said that we must
terminate parts of the Constitution to
either reinstate him we're talking about
2020 here reinstate him to the oval
officer have a completely new 2020
election even though it's almost 2023.
this was crazy and authoritarian and
dystopian and horrifying and Carrie Lake
who recently lost her Arizona
gubernatorial race but has a lawsuit and
is has prayers that she's using to try
to get in office she says Trump was
right to call for the termination of
parts of the Constitution yeah she's
auditioning really hard to be Donald
Trump's VP uh their values right the
Constitution above all else except
except here a massive voter fraud of
this type and magnitude
allows for the termination of all rules
regulations and articles even those
found in the Constitution our great
Founders did not want and would not
condone false and fraudulent elections I
agree with them on that whoa can you
imagine our founding fathers what they
went through to help bring about this
great nation seeing what happened in
2020. nothing happened the person who
got the most votes won it's really
seeing what's happening now in 2022 just
saying okay well I guess it didn't go
our way and I guess they cheated we know
they rigged the elections and they put
in a bumbling fool who doesn't even have
the mental capacity to run this country
okay just get over it we'll just let the
loser take the White House I don't think
that would happen president Trump is
saying we are in unprecedented times and
unprecedented measures are necessary
that is what he is saying right Carey
Lake agrees with Trump terminate parts
of the Constitution now as a reminder
Donald Trump's full statement on Truth
social was quote and this was based on
the Twitter story okay quote so with the
revelation of massive and widespread
fraud and deception and working closely
with big tech companies the DNC and the
Democrat Party do you throw the
presidential election results of 2020
out and declare the rightful winner
or do you have a new election a massive
fraud of this type in magnitude allows
for the termination of all rules
regulations and articles even those
found in the Constitution our great
Founders did not want and would not
condone false and fraudulent elections I
spoke earlier this week to you
with peace and love about the
unfortunate reality that even their most
prized principles and values that they
claim to ascribe to almost like sacred
texts the Constitution Free Speech not
regulating businesses you although okay
you know
they abandoned them at the drop of a hat
at the drop of a pin
if it's not convenient and right now
that sacred text to them the
Constitution
is uh nothing it's toilet paper that you
flush 10 or 15 times depending on the
type of Plumbing that you have
how long is this going to be accepted or
even just looked the other way at by a
large portion of these right Wingers I
think for a long time because they're
all part of it they all don't really
care about their values if the values
are no longer convenient and by the way
how long are people going to keep
interviewing Carrie Lake Fox News often
bills her as former Arizona
gubernatorial candidate okay she ran a
race and she lost for how long does that
keep getting you interviewed I don't
know the answer just asking questions
all right let's stick with the Kerry
Lake stuff for a little bit longer Kerry
Lake lost in Arizona she wanted to be
the governor more people voted for her
opponent Katie Hobbs and Katie Hobbs
will be the governor
couple days ago
um Kerry Lake
put out a statement saying we have a
lawsuit and the lawsuit is going to stop
certification
it did not stop certification so now
Kerry lake has
another lawsuit
another lawsuit and this one is now that
the election is certified it was a bogus
certification so she has a different new
lawsuit let's listen Arizona is at the
tip of the spear and we just had an
election here November 8th which was run
like they run elections in banana
republics and this is why I'm going to
be contesting the election as you saw
earlier this week some of the um I call
them clowns running our circus of
Elections actually certified the
election my opponent Katie Hobbs who
should have recused herself but oversaw
the election in a very shady and shoddy
way actually certified the election and
a lot of America First Patriots were
saying Kerry what are you doing why
aren't you contesting this what's wrong
and what they don't realize is that in
order to contest an election in Arizona
it has to be certified so this sham
election had to be certified for us to
begin contesting it and we will be
contesting it we're going to be filing
our lawsuit on Friday and I'll be
filling you in more later on in this
program about the lawsuit and what's
coming up yes Friday Friday she's going
to very very powerfully inform us about
that so A couple different things number
one earlier in the week she didn't
mention by the way in order to contest
that it needs to be certified the
lawsuit earlier in the week was to
prevent the certification so let's take
a look at that just as a reminder
how possibly can a republican attorney
general sit there and a governor sit
there and allow this Fiasco people in
Arizona have to understand some
Independence and Democrats yeah you look
like idiots on the world stage this
looks like something that would happen
in the worst of banana Republic's Cary
Lake
yeah I mean the Optics and just a little
over an hour the Optics of them um
sitting there and signing their
signature can you imagine to this sham
election they did it back in 2020 two
years ago and many of us gasped and said
how could they do this why can't they
give more time to look into all of the
issues now fast forward 2022 today and
we've got more issues than we saw in
2020 in that sham election we have just
a blatant sabotaging of election day a
disrespect a disregarded
disenfranchisement of election day
voters that's a lot of words and if they
sit there and sign their names to this
sham Certification history will never
forgive them they will go down as as
three of the very worst in history
yeah so then she went on to explain they
have a lawsuit
um so that lawsuit failed the
certification took place a few hours
later now the next lawsuit is to
decertify which of course is not
actually a thing uh this will just go on
and on and then the next layer to this
carry Lake thing is the god layer let's
talk about that next Kerry Lake now
participating in a prayer circle to try
to pray away the stolen election you
know there used to be a time where these
religious conservatives would try to get
people to pray away the gay they would
say if you pray enough and if I pray
enough maybe you won't be gay no more if
you remember that Viral clip they have
moved on I guess from trying to pray for
people not to be gay or for themselves
not to be gay I don't even know
um
to praying for the winner of an election
to lose that's fundamentally what
they're uh praying for here and you will
see Carrie Lake in this video if you
were what if you were watching with her
head bowed in prayer
um
guys this country is really messed up we
cannot be part of thievery and Lord that
which the people have done to try to
steal this election shall come back upon
their own heads for now is the season
and the hour for things to begin to
shift and change as Global Freedom shall
cover this Earth yeah so I would not bet
on that one working necessarily I don't
know that it would put too many eggs in
that basket for lack of a better term
and Carrie Lake continues to invoke God
here's another segment and this is very
much like you know when when an athlete
says well we I I have to thank God for
this victory
and it's sort of like
God is now choosing like who wins a
tennis match that's what's going on or
the like a curling thing or a soccer
game it's it's God and why is god making
the choices in this way did the other
team not pray enough did they not pray
correctly it's all very weird but Carrie
Lake applying that here to uh her
election I guess people can for starters
pray we we really need God yeah in in
this world we need God in our hearts and
our homes and in our country he quite
literally doesn't have a prayer of being
the next governor of Arizona and I know
God's making a big comeback in this
country I feel it I talk to people who
say I started to return to church I
brought God back into our family's lives
it's so important right now we're due
for a couple of Miracles I think it's
just such a fantasy world that these
people live in but I also believe we
have on top of of that we have a really
good court case and we're going to open
people's eyes to what went wrong you
know there's times I felt just like the
voters out there in Arizona
um despondent over the last couple of
weeks right because we had such a we
have such an amazing movement and then I
think about what God you know our father
is doing he's imagine if you if your dad
said to you I have such great hope for
you and I I believe in you so much that
I'm going to put you in charge of
something difficult uh this is just so
crazy listen if God wanted her to win
why didn't she just win right like is is
God is all-knowing and all-powerful and
involved in every absolutely every
decision Sports decisions and you know
who wins the lottery and who wins
elections God is involved everywhere and
yet God allowed Katie Hobbs to seemingly
get more votes and to have the election
certified and imminently to be
inaugurated as the governor of Arizona
and then now you have to pray for God to
change his mind did you not pray enough
before or did you pray the wrong way or
did Katie Hobbs have better prayer or
more prayer it it's just insane and it's
the same type of grift that would get
people to even donate to somebody like
Carrie Lake in the first place will have
all these carry late Clips if you can
stomach them on our Instagram which you
can find at davidpackman show and of
course they will all be on the YouTube
channel
at youtube.com slash the davidpackman
show make sure you're subscribed it is
free and we will be back right after
this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
Dave Farina who's a science communicator
and also author best known for his
YouTube channel Professor Dave explains
I know we have some at least overlap
with our with our audiences Dave really
appreciate your time good to have you on
yeah thanks for having me so you know I
want to talk to you maybe more
specifically in a few about Homeopathy
and GMOs and maybe maybe vaccines but it
seems to me that one of your goals in in
the content that you create is to blend
certainly as we all do being
entertaining and being educational but
specifically creating sort of a
framework to think through an issue
where there are conflicting claims and
at least in principle some kind of
factual or scientific underpinning that
would get us closer to what we might
call the truth how do you approach it
what's your thought process how do you
think about it
um well I mean for the longest time I
was just making purely academic content
on my channel so explaining science but
then lately I've been doing this
debunking content where I sort of go
after prevalent uh purveyors of
disinformation and when I mean I want to
debunk their claims at face value but I
also do try to elucidate you know what
is obviously their motive what are the
narratives they're using to ensnare
people so if I can kind of like unpack
that for people I think some can maybe
uh approach it with A New Perspective
and go okay I see that's sort of the
bias that's led me to to fall for this
kind of a thing there's a whole bunch of
um uh typical uh things that happen in
these conversations one of those can be
that the person you're talking to maybe
doesn't understand the difference
between an opinion and a fact and they
might think you're kind of disagreeing
about one when it's actually a factual
question another thing that can happen
is that it's uh Sam Harris called it the
setting of many small fires which is you
you have you're prepared for a
conversation and you're knowledgeable
but at any time someone can say well but
what about that study from Singapore
which you haven't seen necessarily and
it can sort of feel like an uncontested
claim where I don't know maybe they're
right about that study from Singapore
can you talk about a couple of those or
others and maybe how to best handle
those types of moments sure yeah I I
mean it's obviously we're seeing that
it's rampant in science politics
everywhere
um I mean I as a science communicator
and an educator I like to just find
where there's a disconnect and the
understanding and try to explain that so
I do like to try to explain the science
and you'd be surprised how how often it
is that it's just a misunderstanding of
basic scientific scientific terminology
or a high school level Concepts that if
you just get in there and explain that
okay now that makes a bit more sense but
as you're saying yes there are those
people who are very uh they like to
adhere to a particular narrative because
they derive and identity from it and
they do go oh look at that study over
here look at that study over there well
you know in my debunks I I get into all
that so let's look at that study let's
look at this figure let's look at this
character who are they what are they
saying is that is that accurate how does
that compare to actual science you know
um I like to try to get into the weeds
with it what about that when some some
is something that is brought up maybe
accurately or maybe not that you simply
just haven't heard of it's unlikely that
it changes the overarching narrative or
the bigger truth but you just aren't
familiar with a particular data point
that someone asserts what's a good way
to deal with that yeah it almost never
does change anything unfortunately on
the spot it's hard to counter because
you do have to go and look at that
Source but that's why I make debunking
content because I'm able to be very well
researched with it I'm able to I I like
to just hear what is going on in The
Ether what are people saying what are
people pointing towards then I can go
investigate those sources and 99.9 of
the time it's very easy to go all right
this person is not qualified they have
no clue what they're talking about
they're just spewing an
anti-establishment narrative to cash in
that's all there is to it um but then I
like to try to illustrate that as
clearly as possible when you're in
person yeah it's very hard I don't know
who you're talking about but I mean one
tactic is to say what is more likely
that the entire scientific Community is
either dumb and wrong or lying and
corrupt or this one guy is a liar I mean
it's it's uh it's uh it's very unlikely
that this person is is accurate in what
they're saying do you find that analogy
and or examples can be useful sometimes
in these cases I'm thinking back to you
know earlier in the pandemic there was
all this confusion about raw numbers
versus per capita and understanding the
rate of something versus the raw numbers
and like what one thing that in my
personal life seemed effective to talk
to people about it was so the United
States and
um
Lesotho have different populations if I
told you a hundred people got covered in
the U.S and a hundred people got covered
in Lesotho does that seem like a like an
important comparison or is something
missing and people go oh no yeah because
the U.S has way more people and it kind
of like opens the door a little bit are
those types of things useful mechanisms
absolutely I mean anything you can do to
get somebody to understand but first
just understand science and numbers and
data but also show how others use
numbers to obfuscate what's really going
on or to you know push a narrative
there's a million ways to do it and
anything you can find that that
establishes a line or connection that
can help you get a point across
absolutely it's a great thing to do
let's just to pick something let's talk
a little bit about Homeopathy so okay
whenever I talk about Homeopathy and I
say well uh there's no active
ingredients and in many countries the
packaging has to actually say cannot
does not treat or cure any condition or
disease period and you look at studies
where you can compare Homeopathy to
Placebo and there's uh it doesn't work
and people just get angry with me and
they often will write to me and they'll
say my uncle is a a homeopath or I was
successfully treated with Homeopathy or
whatever the case may be I don't know if
you agree with my position on Homeopathy
I'll let you address that first of
course I do how how do you tackle those
types of rebuttals from from folks about
well with Chiropractic stuff I get a lot
of the same types of emails these can be
tough because there's a lot of emotional
connection right yeah and and that's not
my forte I'll say that right off the bat
I I'm not you know if somebody has a
really strong emotional bias there
towards something it's hard to penetrate
and that's not really my specialty I
like to make these larger you know this
debunking content where I I can go in
and explain to you beyond a shadow of a
doubt why Homeopathy is pseudoscience
now some people are going to engage with
that and some people are going to reject
that and that's just how the cookie
crumbles but um I think that you know my
strategy is to go in and say okay why
would you think that Homeopathy would
work what is the mechanism by which this
could work and now let's compare that to
what we actually know about the
biological sciences about medical
Sciences what is it for something to
work what is happening on the molecular
level mechanistically that would cause
something to work and recognize that
this has no chance of doing that there's
nothing in it it's water or a sugar
capsule or whatever it is it cannot do
anything and Homeopathy to me is the
most incredible example of something
that so blatantly pseudoscientific on
face value it's so indefensible and yet
is penetrating even certain areas of
Academia you know sort of these like
low-level trade universities that are
offering programs in this stuff simply
due to financial Demand right just if
people are going to pay for the program
some institutions are going to offer it
you know not Harvard Medical School
obviously but some place is going to do
it and then that that really feel it's a
vicious cycle now because people then
can point at these things and see
there's validity to it no they're 100 is
not so
Homeopathy seems a little easier to deal
with than Chiropractic in my mind and I
think the one of the tough things about
Chiropractic is there is this kind of
blend where some of the I've never had
it done but some of the adjustments
probably feel good at least in the short
term maybe there's an endorphin release
there's there's maybe a stretching
component there might be something
that's more akin to like massage that
that that is good but then you have all
of the supposed uses and treatments and
the mechanism of subluxation of the
spine through which it supposedly works
and this type of thing Chiropractic is a
very tough one because there's so much
so much there yeah it is tough because I
don't think that Chiropractics is a sham
field at face value I think that there's
there can be something to spinal
adjustment and it's it's it's fine that
that there are chiropractors and there's
something to it but the problem is it
Blends so easily into pseudoscience
largely because you have these I mean
narcissists essentially who they're not
trained doctors right to become a
chiropractor you're not going through
the same educational path as someone
who's becoming like a medical doctor or
surgeon or something like that so they
they definitely know no less about
things that are outside of their
expertise and then but then you have
people that go on the internet and say
I'm a doctor and here's some stuff
that's totally unrelated to
Chiropractics about nutrition or
something like that and you should
listen to me because I'm an authority
and people really fall for it especially
if it has that anti-establishment bite
to it this is what Pharma doesn't want
you to know or Etc you know these kinds
of uh ways of thinking last big issue I
want to talk about and we can spend some
more time on this one you you got into
it back and forth with Matt Walsh from
the daily wire on the topic of trans
people and over the last year you know
if you've watched Trump rallies CPAC and
other places the home of overtly
homophobic and anti-trans rhetoric is
some of what's getting people the most
excited when there's a crowd there of
the folks that go to these types of
events something about it is really
getting people excited the right loves
to say plain and simple we're just
scientifically correct on this trans
issue there's men and there's women and
that's it and just sort of anything else
is kind of like cultural stuff social
stuff woke stuff which you can do but
it's outside of the realm of science
where where do you think the most
fundamental scientific mistake is being
made by the right on this issue I mean
the scientific mistake is that they
ignore science right boys penis girls
vagina is not science that's what you
learn when you're five right but that's
not all right that's not science human
sexuality human physiology is is
exceedingly complex and all this is on
the right is just a dog whistle right
nothing unites people like a common
hatred and people fear what they don't
understand so I like everyone else 10
years ago or whatever it was had to have
that moment where I went oh Trans people
okay that's a thing but I don't
understand why the right didn't learn
anything from the homophobia the the
huge wave of homophobia you know 40
years ago or whatever it was a little
bit before my time but when when Society
had to adjust to the fact that
homosexuality is a thing and it's not
boy and girl make baby and that's how
humans are right homosexuality exists
and also sexuality is on a spectrum and
all these things
gender is the same way and they hide
behind all these false narratives so
every time I try to talk about this you
know somebody says you think there's 76
genders or something like this never
said anything like that it's just about
the differences between sex and gender
right sex being largely chromosomal and
related to the primary sexual
characteristics the external genitalia
and gender identity being something
that's a neuroanatomical construct right
there's a thing such a thing as having
the experience of being male or female
and that's intimately linked to to brain
structure right masculinization and
feminization occurs in the brain just as
it does in the rest of the body to
produce secondary sexual characteristics
Etc and when sex and gender don't align
that's a trans person that's all it is
so I tried to make some content
explaining what trans people are
scientifically uh and I did so for the
layperson at first
um and actually expected to get a little
bit of flack from the left because I
sort of defended like uh Dave Chappelle
and said oh yes he said some problematic
things but ultimately he's not a bigot
and he's just confused he doesn't know
the difference between sex and gender so
let me help try to explain this and just
the onslaught from the right was
astounding I've never experienced
anything like it
um and so in my response I cited papers
you know here are papers studying gender
identity sexuality all of these aspects
of human physiology and behavior as they
are linked to certain areas of the brain
now I'm not an expert in it but when the
title of the paper says gender identity
as uh as correlating with the unscented
nucleus or whatever part of the brain it
is people are studying this I don't know
the status of the field I could dig into
it more and do content on that if people
are interested but this is this is
science when you don't cite any primary
literature and you deny the primary
literature that the other side is citing
you're not pro science you're denying
science and there's science behind
gender identity sexuality all these
things that the right regularly ignores
that's all there is to it it also does
seem as though there's a concerted
effort from the right to focus in on on
a sliver of of the entire issue which if
we think about it like concentric
circles you've got uh all gender all
possible gender topics and then you've
got trans people within that and then
within that you have trans people in
sports but that's not even really the
issue because they don't really seem
that concerned about trans men right and
they also don't seem that concerned
about all sports like for example chess
has women's and men's divisions but it's
not become controversial if a trans
person wants to be in a different right
so they're basically talking about like
weight lifting and swimming and only
when it comes to trans women this is
like the the tiniest sliver of the
totality of the issue and it's a shame
because we we should be able to have
good faith conversations about those
things it is a problem with what we do
with trans people in sports yeah and and
that's another thing I did in the first
video where I was trying to admit that
yeah there's something to talk about
here but they that's they're not
interested in talking about the Dignity
of trans people or even acknowledging
that that trans is the thing that you
can be right right
um they just want to go towards oh
they're having surgeries on children and
this is no they're not no they're not
they're not doing that that's not a
thing that's happening nobody is
undergoing medical procedures as a
prepubescent child that has happened
zero times so uh it's it's just a way
for them to Garner political support by
capitalizing on the fear and anger of
confused people that don't want to
accept what humans are that's basically
it it's also weird how obviously absurd
things slip into the Lexicon where like
for example for a little while it was
puberty blockers on five-year-olds was
like five-year-olds aren't about to go
through puberty why would you why would
you need to do that or prepubescent
girls are having double mastectomies
they don't have breasts what are you
what are you removing how does that work
yeah it's just so blatantly false at
face value how can anybody listen to
this and keep a straight face yeah it's
just a narrative it's just a narrative
that they're pushing that's that's all
there is to it folks we've been speaking
with Dave Farina who's a science
communicator and author best known for
the YouTube channel Professor Dave
explains which I encourage you to check
out Dave really appreciate your time
today thank you thank you for having me
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show well it is
happening again classified items have
been found at a Donald Trump storage
unit in Florida it is the guy who said
no one respects classified information
as much as he does he may have been a
little bit careless with the classified
documents Rolling Stone reports
classified documents found at Trump's
storage unit with swords and wrestling
belts lawyers for the former president
turned over more sensitive documents to
the FBI after conducting an independent
search of his properties
identified additional documents with
classification markings in a search that
spanned three Trump properties including
Bedminster golf truck Club in Jersey
Trump Tower in New York and presumably
also Mar-A-Lago down in Florida
um the documents allegedly made their
way look at this to the storage unit as
part of a three thousand pound transport
of miscellaneous items shipped from
Virginia to Florida they're just in a
storage unit they're like in a pod it
was full of suits and swords and
wrestling belts and all sorts of things
A source told the Washington Post who
asserted Trump had likely never even
been to the unit sources told the post
that the material was turned over to the
FBI which declined to supervise the
searches those familiar with the
investigation also indicated to the post
that classified materials were not
recovered from searches at Bedminster
and Trump Tower only from the storage
unit Trump has been obsessed with
people's handling of classified
information for years and years and
years and it turns out that he is the
worst remember all of this stuff okay
we're going to move on and yet she
didn't know the word the letter c on a
document
right she didn't even know what that
word what that letter meant you know
it's amazing I'm watching Hillary go
over facts and she's going after fact
after fact and she's lying again because
she said she you know what she did with
the emails was fine you think it was
fine to delete 33 000 emails I don't
think so she said the 33 000 emails had
to do with her daughter's wedding number
one and a yoga class well maybe we'll
give three or three or four or five or
something 33 000 emails deleted and now
she's saying there wasn't anything wrong
and more importantly that was after
getting a subpoena that wasn't before
that was after she got it from the
United States Congress and I'll be
honest I am so disappointed in
Congressman yeah so Hillary very very
untrustworthy how about George H.W bush
yep nope that's uh that's also very very
bad he can't be trusted either George
H.W bush took millions of documents to a
former bowling alley and a former
Chinese restaurant where they combined
them so they're in a bowling alley slash
Chinese restaurant okay now that story
of course wasn't true as you might
imagine what actually happened was that
uh the national uh archives
rented a facility which previously was a
laundry and Chinese restaurant the
documents were under the right
possession and supervised at Elk points
it just is not even remotely analogous
but he was bad okay remember Trump's
promise about documents in 2016. on
political corruption we are going to
restore honor to our government right in
my Administration I'm going to enforce
all laws concerning Lord the protection
of classified information
[Applause]
no one will be above the law no one
other than I guess Trump himself it sort
of seems uh also Trump saying he is
better than Obama Bush and Clinton when
it comes to documents they've been given
all the time these are other presidents
all the time needed because you're
supposed to have as much time as you
need and complete deference when it came
to their documents and their papers take
as much as you need Barack Hussein Obama
moved more than 20 truckloads over 33
million pages of documents both
classified and unclassified to a poorly
built and totally unsafe former
furniture store located in a rather bad
neighborhood in Chicago
with no security by the way
George W bush stored 68 million pages in
a warehouse in Texas and lost 22 million
White House emails he lost 22 million
emails can you imagine if I lost two
emails that say this is terrible
it must have been nuclear in those two
[Applause]
so you get it Trump's the best at
everything all the time it will be
interesting if we ever do find out
exactly everything Trump stole on his
way out are there still missing
documents even after this particular
find and we have a situation apparently
here in the United States where top
secret documents intelligence
it seems quite poorly managed to the
point where this can even happen like
there's there's two sides of course to
all of this Trump Insanity on the one
hand no one has really tested our
systems the way that Donald Trump has
tested them
and so him doing this stuff is wacky but
also some of the systems haven't worked
particularly well it's odd that agencies
didn't necessarily know about every
single one of these documents as soon as
they were missing oh some turned up in a
storage unit all right I can't wait for
the defense of this because it always
boils down to
incompetence and as it was someone else
pointing fingers and also this isn't
really a bad thing and also Obama did it
worse and blah blah blah blah blah Obama
yeah that guy you remember him
um I don't know what the next step is on
the classified documents but like we
said after the Mar-A-Lago stuff happened
that was not going to be the the last we
heard about documents and indeed more
have already turned up hey I have a very
I don't want to spend a lot of time in
this on this we've had so much stuff on
the program already there's a video that
came out of a very disoriented visibly
confused Donald Trump at Mar-A-Lago with
Charlie Kirk standing next to him it's a
bizarre video we're Trump says people
were trying to vote for Kerry Lake in
Arizona in miles in five miles long
lines and for 10 hours on Election Day
now that happens to be a lie but let's
listen to what he said the audio is not
great but let's do our best to figure it
out
[Music]
three four five mile long lines
[Music]
and
remember there were a few tabulators
that briefly didn't work
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
folks the line went to outer space some
people are still in line today a month
later there is no hyperbole too absurd
for Donald Trump and you know if this
stuff was true which it's not if there
was only something that could be done to
help those voters where it's hot and
they're elderly and they don't feel well
something like where maybe they could
fill out a ballot and then take it to
the post office or maybe leave it in
their mailbox vertically to be picked up
by the U.S posters Postal Service or
maybe if there were more locations to
vote or maybe if there was early voting
at several hundred locations where
people could go and it would spread out
the crowds if this stuff were true
it would be nice if there were something
that we could actually do about it now
of course we all have to ask ourselves
where was the news coverage of file five
mile long lines Five Mile lines to vote
even Four Mile lines or three mile lines
Trump said it was three four or five if
there was a three do you you realize if
there was a single line that went three
miles to vote
it would have been national news all day
on November 8th and they the only story
was
some lines
and a few malfunctioning tabulators it
really makes you think here's by the way
just another video but the scene at
Mar-A-Lago seems absolutely bizarre here
is Trump I guess looking for Michael
Flynn in a crowd around the same time
that he gave that strange rant
a lot of questions
[Music]
by the way this is Trump at a me at some
event of filled with conspiracy
theorists down there at Mar-A-Lago
[Music]
the food's gonna be good
teams but it's great to have you uh you
know General Flynn is one of my
favorites he's a great gentleman a great
man he's done through hell yeah and
Michael Flynn and other conspiracy
theorists apparently were there I saw
him yesterday he looks better than he
did 10 years ago I don't know what's I
don't know what's going on but where is
he by the way where is he come on get
over here general
of that you're a much more handsome man
right now all right it's gotten very sad
Trump's the DJ trumps the maitre d
Trump's the guy who comes through saying
is is there is there a Flynn here is
there Michael Flynn here it's all
getting wacky there were no 10 hour
Waits there were no Five Mile lines we
have a voicemail number and that number
is 219 to David P this is another
voicemail about me texting people just a
reminder these are scams I'm I'm not
texting anybody
yeah I got one of your texts saying call
me direct message right away but no I
don't have the internet I don't have a
computer I got off that damn petrolic
internet platforms stuff four years ago
well good for you I do listen to you
and I'll
read yeah so listen this this I feel bad
for this guy there are people on YouTube
and because there's hundreds and
hundreds we report them as quickly as we
can okay but they keep popping up
they put my face in their profile
picture
and then they respond to YouTube
comments and go hey love the comment
could you text me or Whatsapp me or DM
me or whatever the case may be
I love everybody but I am not trying to
text any of you these are scams they
will try to steal your money okay report
them to YouTube for impersonation we
report them as well I feel bad
it's we're I'm not I'm too busy to text
with people okay I'm not even texting my
friends back because I'm so busy I'm not
trolling my own YouTube comments looking
for people to text so it is not me at
some point there will be a scam at the
end of the rainbow at some point they'll
try to take money from you or something
I don't even really know what the scam
is on the bonus show today folks very
good news Brittany Greiner has been
released by Russia this was a
one-for-one prisoner swap for arms
dealer Victor bout there are people
saying this was not a fair trade that
this was crazy to release Victor about
okay we will talk about it secondly
we're going to talk about the Indonesian
sex band what does that mean and what
does it mean for producer Pat who will
join me on the bonus show and thirdly
we're going to talk about the real
reason that Iran says it's canceling the
morality police what yes all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at
joinpakman.com oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad beautifully set I'll see you on the
bonus show or back here tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
they're Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crew neck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman at davidpackman.com NYC